so we could go work and go but we just
take off our clothes well that's your
choice I mean it's a free world you want
to do that I think it's the same value
as working on an oil company well and I
don't think it's easy either okay okay
let me just oh come on you think me
getting naked so if I just took off my
clothes and said take some pictures with
me that would be as easy as building
that building no it's different
obviously but I do think that both of
them have difficulties no but equal no
such thing as equal okay okay I would
say one but you have to pick which one's
harder I won't pick one no not for me
man they taking off clothes